si ha seguido las matemáticas y algunos
de los principios de termodinámica de
los últimos vídeos lo que ocurre en este
vídeo quizás puede volar tu mente no
quiero hacerte más expectativas altas
vamos a empezar mejor digamos que tengo
este contenedor y que en el contenedor
tengo partículas de un gas
ok adentro del contenedor están
rebotando todas estas partículas tienden
a crear cierta presión en el contenedor
y con cierto volumen y digamos que hay
aquí n partículas ok tenemos en
partículas cada una de estas podrían
estar en equis estados diferentes
déjenme escribirlo aquí okay cada
partícula
la partícula puede estar en equis
distintas posiciones o diferentes
posiciones estados que quiero decir con
estado oposición bueno digamos que una
partícula déjenme poner que esta
partícula
está solita tiene cierta velocidad y
también puede puede estar en alguna
posición de este contenedor verdad
podría estar arriba o acá con cierta
velocidad si sumamos el la los distintos
estados a los que podría estar tendremos
que puede estar en equis distintos
estados no sé
podríamos tener este estado y tener en
partículas y cada una a tener en x
distintos estados eso podría ser ahora
si cada una tiene x estados distintos
cuántos estados distintos puede tener el
sistema bueno si una partícula a puede
tener x distintos estados y otra
partícula digamos puede estar en otros
equis estados entonces de dos partículas
al multiplicarlo tenemos los posibles
estados en los que pueden estar ambas
partículas verdad entonces si
multiplicamos
es por cada por cada partícula que
tenemos en el sistema es decir por cada
partícula multiplicamos x veces ya que
tenemos x distintos estados tenemos en
total x
multiplicado n veces y eso es
simplemente tenemos x a la n verdad y
eso es todo
en la cantidad de estados distintos que
puede tener este estado es perdón a este
sistema el potencialmente los distintos
estados que se pueden presentar en este
sistema entonces por ejemplo si
tuviéramos sólo 3 entonces tendríamos x
x x x x 3 moléculas tendríamos x x x x x
y eso es x al cubo entonces al final
este número realmente se reduce a x
elevado a la n x elevado a la n de
nuestro sistema
ok ahora digamos que queremos pensar en
cuántos estados un sistema puede tener
ciertos estados tienen menos digamos
quizás si tuviera un contenedor más
pequeño también podría tener menos
estados potenciales es decir si depende
mucho de cómo está distribuido este
sistema por ejemplo puede depender del
volumen verdad voy a crear un estado una
variable de estado que me diga cuántos
estados puede tener este sistema cuántos
estados distintos y me dice esta
variable va a ser cuántos estados puede
tener este sistema así que le voy a
llamar s que es la primera vez en
termodinámica que creo que usamos una
letra que se relaciona con con su nombre
ok entonces vamos a medir ese que son
los estados distintos que se pueden
presentar en el sistema ok y como este
número es muy grande voy a tomar el
logaritmo natural de este ok
sólo para definirlo voy a poner un
logaritmo natural
o que hay un logaritmo natural de x a la
n
ok
aquí lo voy a poner entonces logaritmo
natural de x sale en esto es el número
de estados potenciales que hay o qué
número de estados potenciales y ya saben
pues siempre hay que multiplicarlo por
algún factor de escala digamos así que
déjenme ponerle una una constante aquí
que le va a llamar no sé una caja ok
sólo para que nuestras unidades queden
bien definidas y demás entonces esta es
mi variable de estado si me dan un
sistema yo debo en teoría poderles decir
cuántos estados el sistema puede tomar
muy bien entonces déjenme encerrar esto
en una cajita ahora ya que tenemos esto
bien contemplado ok déjenme copiar este
sistema
copiar y pegarlo
como esta cajita y lo que voy a hacer es
poner otra cajita al lado de esta que va
a compartir este muro son digamos que
son idénticas en tamaño ok pero aquí en
el dibujo no pero vamos a suponer eso
qué pasaría si yo de repente evaporó así
de la nada desaparezco esta pared
ok la vapor hizo de repente bueno
en el primer momento en el que yo la
desaparezca esta no va a ser un proceso
isostático verdad todo esto se va va a
romper el esquema que ya tenía y las
partículas van a empezar a rebotar fuera
de ese muro que desaparece se van a
empezar a mover hacia la derecha van a
empezar a rebotar también en los otros
muros de este nuevo contenedor que
agregué porque pues si ya no tienen en
dónde retener se se empiezan a difuminar
a lo largo de este nuevo sistema verdad
así que la presión empieza a entrar en
flujo el volumen también entre el flujo
y no podemos no estamos en un proceso en
donde podamos definir el volumen o la
presión verdad están cambiando todo el
tiempo así que este volumen digamos el
cielo original era b1 en realidad ahora
aumentamos dos veces el volumen del
contenedor
pensemos sobre alguna otra variable de
estado por ejemplo en la presión la
presión por supuesto va a bajar porque
aumentamos el volumen de hecho
duplicamos el volumen pero qué pasa con
la temperatura bueno la temperatura si
cambia
a ver veamos la temperatura es el
promedio de la energía cinética más o
menos así que todas estas moléculas de
aquí tienen cierta energía cinética
podrían tener distintas cantidades de
energía pero la temperatura es una
medida digamos del promedio ahora si
quito este muro que mantenía las
moléculas cambia la energía cinética
pues no lo cambia así que la temperatura
se mantiene constante y aquí tiene
temperatura de 1 entonces la temperatura
de este nuevo sistema también este 1 y
tú podrías decir oye espera cuando en el
pasado en nuestro cilindro expandimos el
sistema
la temperatura bajaba y la razón era
porque cuando lo expandimos era a través
de un pistón que generaba cierto trabajo
verdad entonces la energía cinética de
las moléculas se transformaba en un
trabajo realizado en este caso solo
desaparecido la pared y estos tipos no
realizaron ningún tipo de trabajo no
realizaron ninguna expansión del sistema
así que la temperatura no cambia así que
esto es interesante pero bueno en este
nuevo mundo qué es lo que ocurre
que eventualmente llega una situación en
donde mis moléculas llenan todo el
contenedor verdad y sabemos no sea al
menos del sentido común que esto ocurre
no es un misterio bueno en esta
dirección empiezan a rebotar dentro de
este sistema y van a seguir rebotando
hacia todos lados de este nuevo de este
nuevo contenedor así que eventualmente
van a tener que llegar a todas las
partes de este sistema ahora vamos a
hacer cierto algunos cálculos por aquí
en esta situación anterior cada
particular podría estar en x lugar es
bueno no no no no podía estar en x
podría tener x estados verdad ahora
puede tener el doble de estado es verdad
porque cada partícula puede estar en 2 2
desde 2x estados diferentes cada
partícula puede estar en esos estados
nuevos y porque es el doble bueno los
estados solo
en realidad se refiere a la posición y a
la velocidad entonces por ejemplo
pensemos en una sola partícula que puede
estar en lugares distintos y que tiene
momentos distintos
ok ve momentos que centrados en realidad
de velocidades distintas entonces a este
le llamamos x ahora si tengo el doble de
volumen en realidad puede estar en dos a
lugares distintos y puede tener las
mismas velocidades correcto entonces
esto simplemente se reduce a 2a por b
que es 2x aunque entonces puede estar en
2x estados distintos si duplicamos el
volumen a través de este experimento que
estamos haciendo entonces cada partícula
puede estar en dos equis estados ok
entonces si tenemos n multiplicamos 2x n
veces así que en nuestra nueva s digamos
si ésta era la s inicial
y ahora tenemos ese final aunque estamos
midiendo la cantidad de estados
distintos a las que puede estar este
sistema y tenemos que a veces el
logaritmo natural del número de estados
potenciales que puede haber en el
sistema que es 2x a la n entonces aquí
va 2x a la n así que me pregunta para
ustedes es cuál es el cambio en s cuando
borre la pared que separaba este este
nuevo sistema entonces por ejemplo aquí
duplicamos este cuarto al doble y está
al desaparecer esta pared
ahora obteníamos este nuevo sistema la
temperatura no cambia así que la energía
cinética se mantiene verdad
por cierto olvide decirles que este era
un proceso a diabético no hay
intercambio de calor así que la
temperatura no cambia cuál es nuestro
cambio en ese nuestro cambio en ese va a
ser igual a nuestra es el final menos la
s
inicial que es igual a quienes la s
final esto es esta expresión de aquí
esto es que por el logaritmo natural de
dos y dos a la enee x a la n verdad esto
distribuyendo el exponente y le restamos
la s inicial que quién era ese inicial
aquí está cada logaritmo natural de x a
la n
a logaritmo natural de x a la n ahora
podemos usar nuestras propiedades de
logaritmo bueno ya sabes que el
logaritmo de a menos veces simplemente
dividirlos verdad esto es igual a k
factor izando laca de ambos términos
logaritmo natural de 2 a la nx10 pm
estoy confundiendo porque estoy poniendo
n minúscula y en realidad es n mayúscula
n minúscula es para moles verdad espero
que disculpen este error vamos a
corregir esto entonces es 2 a la n x a
la n sobre x a la n verdad
así que estos dos se cancelan y
simplemente me queda que esto es el
cabeza es logaritmo natural de 2 a la n
mayúscula o si seguimos usando estas
propiedades la n puede salir del
logaritmo multiplicando y poder
finalmente tendríamos que el cambio en
ese es el cambio en esta variable de
estado que no sabemos aún exactamente
qué es exactamente es igual a k
o más bien sacamos la n primer 10 n n a
logaritmo natural de 2
así que al borrar esa pared obtuvimos
que el número de moléculas tiene dos
lugares
o dos estados perdón el doble de estados
posibles y haciendo todas estas
operaciones nos queda que el cambio es
esta expresión y que fue lo que ocurrió
realmente el digo claramente subieron el
número de estados que podía tener porque
este es un número positivo logaritmo
natural de 12 es positivo n es positivo
y vamos a definir esta acá como un valor
positivo entonces todo esto tiene un
valor positivo y si el cambio fue
positivo quiere decir que ahora hubo más
estados posibles ok esto fue al volar de
repente a la pared ajá
tenemos más estados posibles tiene más
cosas distintas que puede hacer y voy a
voy a escupir una palabra muy rara que
estoy diciendo que la entropía subió es
decir esto viene a esto le vamos a
llamar la entropía la entropía ha subido
qué quiere decir en esencia el número de
estados que tiene el número de estados
posibles que tiene verdad estoy
definiendo ese como el entropía entonces
estados en con los que estamos lidiando
ha subido ha subido por cierto factor de
hecho va a subir un factor de n por
logaritmo natural de 2 verdad esto está
muy bien perfecto ya tenemos una forma
estadística más o menos de interpretar
esta este concepto que es una forma muy
combinatoria de medir cuántos estados
tiene el sistema y si miramos el número
de moléculas que tenemos podemos
determinar perfectamente el número de
estados que tiene el sistema ahora como
esto se relaciona con la s que definió
en el vídeo anterior recordemos que en
el vídeo anterior yo estaba buscando una
función de estado que lidiará con el
calor y definí ese o más bien definía el
cambio n se definía el cambio en s como
el calor agregado entre la temperatura a
la cual fue agregado ok entonces veamos
si podemos relacionar estas dos heces
distintas
principio que encontramos así que
déjenme relacionar la volvamos de nuevo
a nuestro diagrama pv de presión volumen
y veamos si podemos sacar algo útil de
ahí
vamos a hacer nuestro diagrama ahí están
los ejes muy bien ok entonces esta es la
presión
este es el volumen ahora cuando
empezamos y antes de volar la pared
digamos que teníamos cierta presión y
volumen aquí este es un volumen de 1
después borré la pared y ok déjenme
hacerlo un poquito diferente
no quiero que esté ahí déjenme déjenme
ponerlo en otra posición déjenme ponerlo
por aquí aunque entonces este es nuestro
volumen 1 y este es nuestro estado
original en el que nos encontrábamos así
que este es el estado inicial ok
entonces al borrar la pared doblamos el
volumen verdad duplicamos el volumen así
que tenemos este nuevo volumen que es 2
b 1 y al doblar al duplicar el volumen
tenemos otra nueva presión que es menor
verdad y eso nos define el estadio 2
el estado 2 así que como este no era un
proceso cuasi estático no puedo dibujar
la trayectoria que va de s1 s2 ok aquí
al quitar la pared entramos a un proceso
de flujo que no me permite definir bien
la presión y el volumen ok no es no fue
un proceso casi estático entonces en
realidad no sabemos qué fue lo que pasó
entre el estado s 1 y el s2 así que si
quiero determinar que / t o el calor
entre la temperatura que vivimos
en el vídeo anterior si yo tuviera un un
proceso isotérmico para empezar y además
que fuera un proceso casi estático
entonces podría determinar una
trayectoria que vaya de s1 s2
y si tuviera esa situación ok ahora la
recordemos que la s es una función de
estado vimos que el cambio era cero pero
siempre y cuando tuviéramos procesos
cuasi estáticos así que el cambio en
esta entropía
déjenme cuidar más mis palabras el
cambio en ese que es ese 2 - ese 1
debería ser independiente debería ser
independiente de la trayectoria que yo
recorra ok es decir sólo depende de el
punto final y el punto inicial no
importa qué trayectoria lo que hayamos
tomado verdad por ejemplo puede haber
tomado algo así ok
así que cualquier trayectoria que vaya
de s1 s2 tendrá el mismo calor
yendo dentro del sistema de que
cualquier sistema que vaya de ese 1 a
ese 2 no importa su trayectoria tendrá
el mismo cambio la entropía o el mismo
cambio en en la variable s porque aquí
ese era algo que no dependía de otra
cosa más que su posición en el diagrama
así que qué sabemos de este tipo de
sistemas bueno supongamos entonces que
lo hubiera hecho de forma isotérmica es
decir que me estoy yendo por una curva
isoterma donde sabemos que la
temperatura no ha cambiado
ok porque no no le hemos agregado
energía cinética a las partículas es
verdad
digamos que pienso en un proceso teórico
en el cual en vez de hacer algo así como
de volar una una pared baja en vez de
eso digamos tengo aquí mi contenedor
original sus moléculas y le pongo un
depósito de calor que está cierta
temperatura de 1
y aquí podría pensar en un pistón en
donde a lo mejor tenía ciertas rocas que
están empujando esto hacia la izquierda
baja así y poco a poco vamos removiendo
estas rocas a lo mejor con granitos y
los gases van empujando el pistón para
realizar cierto trabajo y hasta recorrer
y recorrer este volumen entero aunque
entonces la temperatura se mantiene
constante debido al depósito de calor y
este tipo de proceso digamos es una
versión horizontal de lo que hacíamos
con el ciclo de carnota verdad así que
iríamos ahora de ese 1 a ese 2 a lo
largo de una curva isoterma por ser un
proceso cuasi estático y se vería algo
así como una comunidad hipérbola o un
pedazo de una hipérbola para este
proceso cuál es el área debajo de esta
curva
cuál es el área
entonces bueno el área debajo de la
curva simplemente es la integral la
integral ya hemos hecho muchas veces
esto de nuestro volumen inicial al final
que es el doble ok de la presión por
diferencial de b ajá y p es simplemente
nuestra altura en esta gráfica y esto va
sumando áreas de rectángulos
infinitamente delgados y que nos da el
área esencialmente eso es lo que estamos
haciendo para obtener el trabajo y el
trabajo que éste el sistema realiza por
ser un proceso isotérmico es igual al
calor que le agregamos porque nuestra
energía interna no cambia así que esto
que es hemos hecho esto un buen de veces
así que déjenme ponerlo de una vez esto
es la integral debe 1 2 b 1 de p pero
pepe es igual a en rt así que p es igual
a n rt sobre b diferencial debe ok
este es una temperatura 1 todo esto
ocurre a lo largo de una curva isoterma
así que esto es integre esta es la
integral de v1 a2 b1 sacamos las
constantes en rt 1 y queda la integral
de 1 entre b bebe y hecho esta integral
muchas veces así que de una vez me voy a
saltar unos varios pasos y esto me queda
nrc uno por el logaritmo natural de 2 b
1 sobre b 1 y entonces los ve unos se
cancelan porque bueno primero la anti
derivada de 1 entre bs el logaritmo
natural nos queda este cociente y
simplemente nada más de cancelar esa
parte de v1 nos queda nrc 1 logaritmo
natural de 2 muy interesante ahora vamos
a agregar un detallito más un detallito
interesante a esta ecuación así que en
rte si yo quisiera escribirlo en
términos del número de moléculas n estã
n minúscula podría reescribir la como
el número de moléculas sobre 6 por 10 a
la 23 verdad muy bien eso es lo que estã
n minúscula significa así que qué bueno
recordemos que todo esto lo tratábamos
de encontrar para ver la cantidad de
trabajo realizado por el sistema verdad
pero si lo hacemos de esta forma la
ecuación se convierte en bueno déjenme
ver el trabajo como es un proceso casi
estático va va de este estado el inicial
al al estado 2 va a hacerlo en una forma
cuasi estática y eso se traduce al área
debajo de la curva pero el trabajo
realizado por este sistema es igual a n
r sobre 6 por 10 a la 23 por t 1
logaritmo natural de 2 que esto es lo
que obtuvimos ahorita ok vamos a llamar
a esto una nueva constante que le va a
poner acá convenientemente verdad y que
de hecho éste se reduce a nk que de
hecho se llama la constante de boltzmann
ok simplemente es r dividirlo entre 6
por 10 a la 23 por t 1 logaritmo natural
de 2 muy bien
ahora esto es en esta situación la otra
situación en no realizamos ningún
trabajo porque no podríamos describir la
trayectoria así que este sistema hizo
cierto trabajo y como lo hicimos a lo
largo de una isoterma el cambio el
cambio la energía interna es igual a
cero así que el cambio en la energía
interna es igual al calor aplicado al
sistema menos el trabajo realizado por
el sistema y finalmente si esto es cero
tenemos o concluimos que el trabajo
realizado es igual al calor que le
agregamos así que el calor agregado al
sistema para por nuestro depósito de
calor va a ser igual
el calor agregado va a ser igual a nk
porque uno baja por la temperatura de la
que estábamos en la isoterma por el
logaritmo natural de 2 ok
entonces esto puede multiplicar por dos
el volumen ahora en el último vídeo
definía el cambio en s como q / t verdad
que es que el calor agregado entre la
temperatura la cual fue agregado así que
para este sistema que es un sistema casi
estático cuál fue el cambio en ese que
tanto se cambió mi s mi estado s
qué es el calor agregado entre la
temperatura de uno así que si
sustituimos esto es n por la constante
de boltzmann por t 1 logaritmo natural
de 2 y dividimos todo esto entre t 1 así
que estos se cancelan y simplemente nos
queda que nuestro cambio en ese nuestro
camiones es igual a n k logaritmo
natural de dos y ahora deberías empezar
a tener una experiencia de esos que uno
dice ah claro porque cuando definimos en
el vídeo anterior esta está este cambio
en el en la variable s solo vimos que
era una variable de estado aceptable
ok definiéndolo de esta forma que era el
calor aplicado entre la temperatura a la
cual el calor fue aplicado y cuando
usamos esta definición el cambio en
nuestro valores de esta posición a otra
sólo depende del inicio y del final
verdad
y resultó ser esto ahora esto es una
función de estado es una variable de
estado no es dependiente de la
trayectoria así que en cualquier proceso
es esto toma el mismo valor de este
punto a este otro punto no importando la
trayectoria que yo recorra ok esto va a
tomar un cambio en ese que es igual a n
a logaritmo natural de 2
cualquier sistema por definición verdad
no importa cómo
nos movimos a lo largo de esta
trayectoria pudo haber sido muy loco
solo es una función que depende del
estado inicial y el final así que cuando
empezamos el vídeo empezamos con esta
nueva definición de la s ajá moviendo el
volumen al volar la pared y demás pero
en el vídeo anterior con esta definición
de cambio de s llegamos a que se
obtienen las mismas expresiones ok
y bueno ahí habría que refinar algunos
detalles de las constantes pero
obtuvimos el mismo resultado desde un
punto de vista estadístico baja del
número de estados distintos que puede
tomar el sistema y lo que es algo para
viajar la mente es que es es una bonita
es un bonito macro estado en el mundo
digamos de los de las máquinas de
carnota
estamos midiendo realmente el número de
estados que el sistema puede tomar así
que todo este vídeo largo que hasta
parecería fácil de hacer en dos vídeos
es una introducción de la entropía la
entropía y en termodinámica un cambio en
la entropía baja la entropía es ese yo
creo que se refiere a estados en inglés
por ejemplo en un ciclo de carnoedo en
una máquina de carne es el calor
agregado entre la temperatura la cual se
agregó ahora en nuestro mundo de la
mecánica estadística podríamos definir
la entropía como una constante ok
una constante que de hecho es la
constante de boltzmann baja que está
constante que multiplica que multiplica
al logaritmo natural del número de
estados que tenemos que el número de
estados vamos a llamarle omega ok a
veces a veces es conveniente hacerlo de
esta forma y lo que he mostrado en este
vídeo es que son definiciones
equivalentes al menos para algunos de
estos casos no para este caso en donde
hice este experimento de incrementar el
volumen verdad y obtuvimos este mismo
resultado y cuando usamos la definición
termodinámica también llegamos a ese
mismo resultado si suponemos que esta
constante es la misma y realmente es la
misma la misma constante de boltzmann
entonces nuestra definición nuestras dos
definiciones son equivalentes y la
intuición de entropía quizás sigue
costando trabajo porque no es realmente
fácil de entender pero el cambio en la
entropía más y significa más o menos el
cambio del número de estados que el
sistema puede tener ya sabes al veces en
alguna clase de química te dirán que es
similar al desorden del sistema pero no
quiero que piensen en el desorden como
si estuviéramos hablando de un cuarto no
sé de tu habitación que está muy
desordenada sino no quiero que hablemos
de ese caso más bien pensemos en un
estadio lleno de gente tienen más
estados un estadio lleno de gente que un
estadio sin gente ok tiene tiene mayor
entropía o quizás debería ser más
cuidadoso el estadio a una alta
temperatura digamos a mitad del día que
cae todo el sol tiene más entropía que
lo que hay dentro de mi refrigerador que
las partículas en el estadio tienen más
estados que las partículas en mi red en
mi refrigerador y así que les voy a
dejar con estas dos definiciones que ya
vimos que son equivalentes en estos
y vamos a aplicar esto para hablar un
poquito de la segunda ley de la
termodinámica de hecho esto está omega
que escribí aquí como les decía en
realidad es 2 a la n verdad son 2 a la n
para el caso en que tenía el volumen
inicial perdón cuando cuando yo tenía x
la primera vez era x a la n 2 alain
perdón y al multiplicar por dos el
tamaño del cuarto entonces tenía 2 a la
enee x a la n solo quiero asegurarme de
que está omega se relacione con lo que
vimos en este vídeo de cualquier modo
nos vemos